on a attendu après tout 8h45 réunion
d'affectation dans la salle des
nouvelles de radio-canada nous proposer
un sujet de reportage
dominique degré étudiant en journalisme
présente le sujet qui l'intéressent en
vue de la réalisation de ce reportage
je suis ici dans le cadre du projet
premier vote j'ai pensé que le reportage
qu'on ferait aujourd'hui laurent et moi
porterait donc justement sur la
participation des jeunes en politique
en 2011 le taux de participation chez
les 18 24 ans n'atteignait pas les 40%
bien en-deça de la participation
nationale
mais selon sept chercheurs à
l'université mcgill que dominique a
rencontré il est faux de croire que les
jeunes électeurs ne s'intéresse pas à la
campagne électorale dans l'étude
canadienne de la jeunesse que nous avons
menées à midi et à l'uqam
nous trouvons que il n'ya qu'à peine 10%
des jeunes qui disent ne pas
s'intéresser du tout à la politique et
aux enjeux publics selon valériane mahéo
les jeunes électeurs se méfie des
promesses des candidats
il se présente peu aux urnes mais
participe différemment à la vie
politique
selon les résultats de l'étude
canadienne de la jeunesse 50 % des 18-24
ans boycottent les marques qu'ils
n'approuvent pas 60% signent des
pétitions et 70 % font des dons pour
soutenir des causes sociales ou
politiques
dominique s'est rendu à l'université de
montréal où les bureaux de vote par
anticipation ou vrai aujourd'hui la
majorité des jeunes lui ont dit qu'ils
iraient voter
mais ils sont critiques envers les
politiciens on pense que nos voix dans
ce moment ne sont pas entendues au
parlement tant que ça vaut pas la peine
moi l'élection
tant pis ça m'intéresse pour moi c'était
plus de 6 en grande partie une
impression qu'il n'y a pas grand chose
qui va changer une chose est sûre les
jeunes électeurs qui participent au
projet premier vote ne s'intéresse à la
campagne électorale suivez leurs
questions pour les candidats sur
instagram avec le mot-clic premier vote
et si laurent terrière radio canada
montréal